[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting it's part four of I think
what we're calling for total episodes
and our Lost years slash spiritual
journeys hopeless hope we're calling it
for parts if it is 34 well there may be
other parts I mean well yeah yeah that's
one of the conversation so in in part 1
& 2 we discuss what happened externally
between college and becoming youtubers
and then in parts 3 you you you discuss
what happened more internally with you
in terms of your spiritual
deconstruction and here we are at part 4
it's my turn to spill my guts and I've
I'm gonna spew my guts all over these
notes I've taken because yeah just like
you I really I wanted to this is a great
exercise for me to organize my thoughts
I think as I share I think there'll be
elements of it that I'm still it'll be
kind of obvious that I'm still
processing so I think it's it's been a
very it's been very good for me to prep
for this episode I feel emotional I I
think just in general and also nervous
to share well you know before you get
into it I will say that you know having
having shared first mmm-hmm
I mean think I told Jessie when I got
home is like I was like man I just feel
like this giant weight has been lifted
off of me you know like is it because
it's kids because we talked about it
well it's because they well it shouldn't
I feel like there's this story that I've
had that is is is so personal and you
kind of carry it around and you know how
much it has impacted who you are yeah
but you know how kind of touchy it is to
talk about it and to just get out there
like I started realizing how much
emotion I had kind of attached to it but
it was actually more kind of after I had
done it that it sort of like kind of
released a little bit did you weep in
the shower
I don't remember weeping but no it's
just yeah what I'm giving it a second
hour it's it's it is super emotional and
I will say also that you know bunch of
you are already kind of using hashtag
your biscuits on Twitter is probably the
best place that's where you know yeah
thanks for sharing your responses
easiest way to kind of find what people
are thinking and help you people are
processing we've been reading some
people's stories and a lot of people
have clarifying questions and yeah that
follow-up questions for us hashtag yeah
so if you guys want to share your
experience if your response if something
comes up in the middle of linked stories
like pause it write that question down
we want your questions so we're not
trying to like close the book on this
process we don't know how often we're
gonna revisit this subject but it now is
a part of what we're doing on your
biscuits so we want this to be an
ongoing discussion we are still in
process yeah and we want you to be a
part of that so and also I want to thank
you for sharing these episodes this
particular series with people that you
think it will resonate with or it
becomes grounds for conversations with
friends or former friends or whatever
your situation is thanks for sharing
what we're doing here with with people
so that that means a lot to us too
all right let me get into it I I think
I'm I was trying to figure out why I was
so nervous and you know Kristi really
helped me process this and I think it's
that I don't want to disappoint people
for some reason I mean not only
dedicated mythical beast who may find
out that my beliefs don't align with
theirs
but also my friends both past and
present and my extended family I mean
this is not something that I've there's
been an occasion for me to discuss this
with them you know and I just because I
just didn't want I don't want to I don't
want to disappoint them you know so one
thing I want to say I don't intend to
and I hope that no one listening feels
implicated in my story
I'm grateful for the path that I've
taken for the pain and the joy and the
mistakes and the thrills associated with
it because I don't think there was any
other way for me to get to here and I
know that I'm extremely fortunate
because I know that there's so many
people who've had deeply traumatic
experiences associated with their own
spiritual journeys so I'm grateful I'm
still in process and this is my story up
to this point and I am gonna go back I I
want to start by telling a couple of
stories just to give you snapshots of
just to help you feel what it was like
to be me
growing up in an evangelical Christian
environment so I'll just go ahead and
get into the first story in 1988 I was
10 years old and Buies Creek First
Baptist Church the church that I'd gone
to my entire life you know I didn't have
any memories of not going to this church
so also the church that you started
going to and with your family when you
when you moved here in first grade they
were holding a revival mm-hmm which is a
series of nights where you get together
and there's speakers and it it gets real
didn't happen all the time but it did
happen this year and it was called
contact 88 and the t-shirt yo he was
read with like a and a cool 80s font
contact idiot it seemed more like it was
about like extraterrestrials
getting to know us right but it was
really about making contact with God I
think in an Irish guy was he not
Scottish
or was he Irish uh well as you know I'm
trying to blur the lines between those
two things these days so in my memories
the dude is Scottish so this preacher
that came in from out of town I guess
way out of town
was preaching at least on this last
night like the culmination night this is
the big one people gonna make decisions
this night he's he gives a sermon and he
explained that every person who's born
into this world is born in a sinful
state even before you've done anything
wrong you have a compulsion to do things
wrong you have this selfishness you know
you're in sin put that in quotes and God
who created you is being perfectly just
just cannot abide by this these
shortcomings that we have baked into who
we are as humans so that's got to be
punished
you got a and and the punishment is not
just it's not a minor punishment here
because it's it's if you're in any short
of God's standard of perfection
well that that shortcoming needs to be
paid for it somebody it's got to be
taken out on somebody so that's when it
came to this concept of eternal
separation from God and I'm I'm pretty
sure there was a mention of like eternal
torment in sin some fiery hell right so
as a 10 year old just imagine 10 year
old link I was still sleeping with a
pound puppy mmm you know and this was
this was a big deal if this was
something that was talked about in our
church but it was different in revival
you were really listening and it sounds
like this is a big deal I mean eternal
damnation that's scary and especially if
it's coming from a guy who came all the
way from Scotland or Ireland to tell me
about it I do think he was rolling his
arse which i think is a Scottish thing
yeah it was it was it was it was it was
enrapturing yeah but it scared us
I just love his accent how could it not
scare you you know but then he explained
that God is not only perfectly just he's
also perfectly loving and he wants to
make it another way for us to have a
relationship with him and not be
eternally separated or currently
separated from God and it turns out
God's solution is that he sent his son
to come to your come to earth Jesus live
a perfect life never deserve an ounce of
punishment or God's wrath or hell or
damnation but then willingly take it on
himself anyway and he was executed hung
on a cross crucified died and paid the
penalty instead of us as individuals
paying the penalty and then he rose from
the dead he resurrected and how he's
seated at the right hand of God and he's
listening to this sermon right now you
know so and he also is God and he also
has got that's an important part of that
too and that happened that happened some
1988 years ago at the time and well all
you yeah give or take give or take 33
yeah so you've got so then he Scottish
dude explained all you got to do is
accept the fact that he took the
punishment that you deserved and you
also have to get up out of your pew and
you got to walk down here in front of
everybody by the way but man I was so
scared
and I was like I knew other people I
knew you had already done this well can
I just say I remember being at contact
Eddie a-and I remember I remember seeing
you get up and I was thinking I was like
it's about damn time I mean I was I did
this when I was six yeah
I was like what I mean what why is he
taking so long you know you're you you
thought you were little Scott does he
not understand the gospel like I
have to be double digits were you
waiting to be double digits because I
was like I don't know what the age of
accountability is but all I know is I
don't want to die and go to that's a bit
of a late bloomer and I thought that uh
I think that was my age of
accountability yeah I think everybody's
age of accountability is different
especially if you're still sleeping with
a pound puppy it's like a free pass uh
yeah I went I remember I by the way
we're using a lot of Christianese yeah
the age of accountability is the age at
which if you aren't a Christian and you
die you won't go to hell because or just
before that you yeah because you don't
you don't you're not old enough to
process can't make the decision for
yourself and it's nowhere in the Bible
it's just some you kind of have to come
up with theologically because if you
don't have it it's it's pretty bad what
the kids going to hell I understood it
that day right and so I got up the
gumption and I went forward and I
remember that they paired you off at
people and I got to be led in a prayer
by Amy Moore this girl you know I was 10
this girl was like in high school it was
amazing yeah and she said repeat after
me and I I accepted Jesus did for me and
from and at that point I'm like Jesus
rose from the dead he saved my life I'm
glad I don't have to worry about that
he'll thing anymore and I owe this guy
everything this preacher or Jesus Jesus
okay
and I really like Scottish people now
there might be Irish but I don't want to
talk to them because they are scary and
I was like you know what I'm doing this
movie this is this is my life now I got
it I got it all set set up and I'm
singing in the choir next week I sing in
a choir with a bunch of adults the next
on the following Sunday still wearing
out contact 88 t-shirts
I was beaming mm-hmm I was a little bit
jealous I was like maybe I should have
waited
I could sing in the choir I want a
fast-forward to high school and tell it
a second snapshot that was just very
formative you want to tell that story
before or after Brussels let's tell it
after a quick break no I'll have a quick
break go to mythical calm and get this
sweatshirt
also get this ear biscuits mug we've
been told we're making anymore limited
supplies there's down to less than 100
of these mugs and we're not doing it
again
I mean this is it this is the ear
biscuits mug at least in this current
form so if you want one of these and you
don't want to complain about it after
it's gone you've got to go to mythical
calm and get it so in high school
everything we were still very involved
in church and in youth group I mean if I
had to rank the things that I associated
my identity with yeah I was I was a
soccer player in high school and it's
pretty amazing at it I don't know what
else I would say besides that but that
would be number three math Olympiad math
um idea but number one would definitely
be that I was a Christian you know
everybody knew that that like we were
really involved in our youth group we
had friends who weren't involved but
like our closest friends were and we you
know we were we were truly devoted to
God as as high schoolers we clowned
around but we were we would devote it
and we understood it not just as a
belief system but as a relationship with
God like you said last week that was
something that we were actively pursuing
talking to God through prayer in a
conversational way really figuring out
how the Bible applied to our everyday
lives and it we tended to you know you'd
boil it down to some some oversimplified
things or at least in action like we
didn't cuss not in public at least right
we didn't fool around with our
girlfriends or we felt guilty about it
when we did it leaves us but yeah and we
definitely did not drink oh that was an
easy one that was an easy I mean I was
it was illegal yeah
that would that would be extreme I did
listen to the red Chili Peppers but I
felt bad about it and I was called out
on it bias
of our our friends in the youth group
but one Saturday night our friend Trent
who was not involved in our youth group
I'll just I'll just put it that way his
parents were out of town that weekend so
he threw a party on a particular
Saturday night
you know what story I'm going to tell I
remember this night so he threw this
party and I decided to go I was 16 I was
able to drive myself and I told my mom
I'm spending the night at Trent's house
she was fine with that
you did not go to this party at all I
wasn't there for any and then left you
may have been there earlier but my
recollection is that you were not there
at all but you could have left early
that's my recollection but we know how
recollection goes around here I
definitely know what happened after you
left if you were there and that's they
broke into Trent's parents liquor
cabinet
or I think they just opened it right it
started drinking stuff I wasn't chained
trans older brother was there that
seemed to make me a little more
comfortable but I wasn't I wasn't gonna
drink because that wasn't me I mean we
were we you know I had to preserve my
witness since what you call it when it's
like your your reputation is someone
who's like God is God is enough for me
so I don't have to search for other ways
to be happy was like this message that
you were trying to send I think to your
to to our friends that's what we wanted
to do but after a while I just I was
like you know what screw it I just want
to have a little fun I'm gonna drink for
the first time ever and I did a lot and
a the majority of everybody there was
was drinking and you know I got drunk I
didn't do anything
I didn't do anything specific that I
regret besides maybe the decision to
break the law and it was you know a lot
of my mom and but my I was just you
probably do some annoying thing I was
I'm sure I did a lot of annoying things
I was very silly and didn't feel too
great and so I remember when when the
party had died down and everybody was
like everybody it would
was crashing wherever they were going to
crash I crashed in this guest room with
our friend Jason so we're like you know
trying to go to sleep and I just
remember staring at the ceiling and
feeling so guilty and I said out loud to
him I was like man this guy I'm supposed
to be an example to him as what it means
to have a relationship with God I'm like
I just want I just feel so bad what I
did
doubt that's not me man this isn't me
this is I just remember saying this
isn't me I'm just really sorry I did
this and he was like hey man just just
go to sleep you'll be all right next
morning we woke up and Jason was in
there scrambling eggs for everybody it's
just a new day it was like nothing had
happened but for me it was like my life
had changed I I just like it was that
big of a mistake in my mind and Jason
said you should suck on some panties and
I was like what he said when you go home
he had all the secrets but on the way
home you need to suck on some pennies so
your mom doesn't smell liquor on your
breath he just smells money and so I had
to get home because I was had to go to
go to church and you know my head was
pounding had a hangover felt horrible
and I opened my ashtray when I got in
the truck to drive off and I just where
I kept all my loose change and I got a
handful of pennies and threw him in my
mouth and sucked on pennies all the way
home I felt so bad when I got home I
told mama I just can't I don't feel good
I I can't I can't go to church today
she's like okay fine and then but we did
have to go to nanny's for lunch cuz you
don't miss nannies for lunch and I I
could not get off the couch
I felt so bad so I'm laying on the couch
and after lunch there and we're all
sitting in there hanging out and I'm
just laid out and I remember my mom
looking at me just say Linc you look you
look like you've you're hungover
haha and I was just like I just I think
it was something I ate what does that
mean yeah I think it was pennies I eat
pennies yeah I just sucked on him I
didn't swallow that was all she said we
never my mom and I have never talked
about it since then
not one of those things that comes I
don't listen to this sorry mom but that
afternoon you came by and we got in your
car and we were hanging out and we did
what we would always do we were 16 17
years old that we would just drive
around and talk and listen to music
right I remember we were doing that this
day and I knew that you were gonna find
out that I had gotten drunk the night
before I mean if I didn't tell you
somebody else is gonna tell you and that
it would be better for you to find out
from me that was tough I remember we
were driving I'd I told you that Trent's
party last night I I got drunk and you
looked at me and you slowed this slow
the car down and then you pulled over on
the side of the two lane country road
that we were driving down beside a field
and I looked at it to you and you looked
at me and you said get out oh wow and I
I said what what he said get out man and
I open the door I got out and just
picture an extremely wide cinematic shot
of a guy standing on the side of the
road beside a car in the middle of
nowhere Harnett County just fields and a
few farmhouses in every direction you
look
and you drove off and I just stood there
and I knew how to get home
because we had driven all these roads
but it was at least six miles away he
were good ways out it was at least six
miles maybe eight for my house I started
walking cuz you just you didn't stop I
mean you went straight down that long
straightaway and then you disappeared
over the horizon and I just started
walking home and I started thinking
about the decision I had made and it was
like the biggest decision I guess I
would have described it at the time as
an act of rebellion I don't know if
that's what it was but it was it was a
big mistake in my mind and I just
started crying like weeping like tears
just just flowing off my face and just
walking down in the grass on the side of
this road and okay you know I remembered
I it was hard to see where I was going
you know if I was gonna step in
something and I remember looking up how
far do I have to go to even clear this
hill and then I saw you coming back over
the hill first I saw your head then I
saw your shoulders and then you cleared
the hill and you were walking you
weren't in your car you were walking on
the side of the road and it was kind of
awkward because it's a long ways the box
okay I get it you're walking but we
finally did
we met you know we were walking towards
each other and I don't remember exactly
what I said but I know it was basically
I'm so sorry for what I did and I it
wasn't that I had I wasn't sorry that I
disappointed you
it was that I was so sorry that I
disappointed God and I mean I don't
think we I don't think there was a hug I
don't think there was a handshake I
think that our mo at the time was like
just we knew what we both felt and what
we thought and about what had happened
and I you know I interpreted it as like
a physical representation of not only
the fact that you love me as a friend
but that God forgave me that you know I
think it was I we tended to think a lot
in terms of symbolism you know and so I
don't know how much of that was going
through your mind but I think that it
really hit home for me I just felt like
this is a big deal there was a lot of
disappointment here but I'm not you know
I'm not God hasn't rejected me
I'm already I'm already forgiven and we
walked back to the car we got in and we
we drove off and yeah it was just a
picture of forgiveness and I think it
was really powerful and I mean the thing
is we were we were devoted to God and we
were devoted to helping each other stay
devoted you know the it was so important
to us and we were steeped we were
steeped in the teachings that our church
in our family gave us and experiences we
had within the church so then when we
went to college and got involved in
Campus Crusade
Christ all of a sudden everyone in that
group was also devoted to God in the
same way everybody wanted the same thing
it was it was actually it was exciting
because it was so much easier for me to
be who I'd lived my entire life aspiring
to be somebody completely sold out for
Jesus you know I think we we in Episode
one we painted this opportunistic
approach to like our involvement in
Campus Crusade that like really served
our career and I just you know there was
absolutely and I do think we we talked
about it there was a parallel path of
like spiritually and personally this is
this is what this is how we wanted to
live our lives this is this is a perfect
scenario for that you know it was yeah
we weren't there we weren't there first
and foremost to try to become comedians
or have an audience because we didn't
even know we didn't even know that was
an option it was like this is what we
want these are the these are the people
that we want to be around so that so the
things that we weren't doing and the
things that we were doing may seem a
little odd like I mean it wasn't any
partying ever in like the traditional
tropas collegiate sense there was a lot
of group dates going on you know if you
were interested in to somebody there was
like the the way to be is as pure as
possible about approaching dating I was
really good at organizing those I could
I can have a men's Bible study taking
women's Bible study out for a distant
night on the town and you know as long
as you know group it's like you you know
nothing out of trouble
Christy and I never kissed until we were
engaged to be married
you know it was and that was that was my
decision that's not something that
anybody forced on me you know it would
that wasn't the action like the specific
teaching of anybody but as I did not
subscribe to that particular you know I
had interpretation I had come off a
relationship in my senior year of high
school freshman year at college that
I felt like I had made mistakes and not
being self controlled and I was eat up
with guilt associated with that and I
just did not want to screw up my
relationship with Christian and because
I saw that has so much potential and I
wanted to please God
you know and I wanted to do it right you
know how I think there's a there's a
best way to do everything there's a
there's a perfect execution of of
everything and I'm gonna try to its
safest if I stay within that you know
especially when it comes to
disappointing God or not so so yeah we
were it may seem odd to you lizard or a
great hand holder I'm assuming that way
yeah like I was so calculate I was like
I'm only gonna go out on a date with her
once a month and we're only gonna talk
once a week and I won't hurt it
you know I won't hurt her I don't want
to get in the way of her being devoted
to God and I want God I want to be
devoted to God in her second and um you
know I I felt for the old me reading
back through my journals but and I'll
read one in a second but I just wanna I
want to say that yeah I was I was
extreme because of just the way I
interacted with the environment and the
teaching but it was thrilling to be like
like like we said before we it was
thrilling to answer a higher calling to
connect with God and to go through it
with really great friends it was the
most meaning and satisfaction I'd ever
experienced in my life
mm-hm you know within that context but
you in as I prepped for this I did go
back and I reread through my journals
and whenever I would journal it was
always in the form of prayer I was
writing a letter to God because it was
hard for me to pray but if I wrote it
down at least I could concentrate and I
could get my thoughts out and it was at
least my side of the conversation with
God you did that to something right yeah
but I want to read an excerpt from this
one journal entry from just my junior
year so at January 20th 1999 okay so
this is what I wrote Lord I'm frustrated
about us I just feel guilty that it's
not clicking like I'm just bad or wrong
or lazy or something I'm tired of
feeling pressure and guilt to spend time
with you
Lord I would quit trying altogether if I
didn't know how stupid and mindless that
would be to whom shall I go which was
like my paraphrase of a a Bible verse
meaning where would I turn if I if I
turned away from God
it wasn't just that journal entry like
the vast majority of my journal entries
over those years it was it was actually
heartbreaking they were they were filled
and I'm talking like eighty percent of
anything I would write it was filming me
apologizing for disappointing God a lot
of guilt a lot of shame a lot of
frustration for not being devoted enough
and I did I didn't I didn't really
appreciate or recall that internal
struggle that I was having I'd kind of I
kind of forgotten that until I went back
and started reading through the journals
and I was a little bit shocked he's not
that I journaled all the time and I I do
think there's a factor of I would
journal when I felt like I really needed
my my my relationship with God needed a
kick in the pants like I really needed
to like buckle down and so I and then if
maybe if things were going better I just
didn't journal maybe that's another
explanation but it was a lot of a lot of
my private experience I think was was
kind of defined by that level of shame
and frustration and I again I don't tell
me what you I don't want to imply that
the main teaching from crew or our
churches the church that we grew up in
was really super legalistic I don't I
don't think they they were not so
legalistic there was not a constant
emphasis on following certain rules the
emphasis was on having like a personal
relationship with God but they were
there are there are factors associated
with going about that relationship that
the way that I internalized that was
that I was failing at it that I didn't
have what like the people who it was
really working for had that I was very
hard on myself well I I would say that
we were on a spectrum so I would say
that compared to just the general
population we were legalistic without a
doubt oh yeah because we did have a
bunch of rules that were sort of you
know interpretations of the Bible that
and applied to our specific situation or
a specific culture that kind of led to
things like not kissing your your
girlfriend until you're engaged to be
married but but I do think that most of
this is just the way that different
personalities interact with it because
yeah yeah for me I was having all those
intellectual thoughts and doubts and
that's a lot of the stuff that I would
be like writing about and thinking about
but when it came to and of course I felt
like oh I'm prideful and I'm lustful and
all that you know the the the the ways
that I thought I was sinful but I think
I kind of gave myself more of a break
then you did just because that's my
personality I don't think I was
hardening myself that I would that I
sinned I was hard on myself that I
didn't have a quality of relationship
with God where I was motivated to
connect with him to pray to do like the
spiritual disciplines like study the
Bible and pray and the things that I
felt like we're a true test of intimacy
with God like our the humans role in
that I felt like I just I was I was
trying to pull myself up by my
bootstraps I was I was trying to conjure
something that I didn't
that's that came naturally to people who
had like a true kin
I also think you were perceiving that
that was happening with people and I and
I think that everybody has their own
struggle you III don't think it was like
but it's interesting that and I think we
had to have talked about it but it I
kept going back to it so much in my
journal that like it's just something
that I couldn't shake because of and I'm
starting to understand myself now in a
way that I never have and so I can see
things that I've learned about myself
now in terms of like an unhealthy view
of being a perfectionist being a one on
the Enneagram if you're if you're into
that I do think it was me discipline
being disappointed in myself more than
people telling me that God was
disappointed in me hmm and then in you
know when I graduated Chris you know I
got married there was another level of
pressure because then the teaching was I
was to assume the role of the spiritual
leader that's what it was called it's
like you you know
initiate prayer with your your family
and like make decisions and make sure
you're doing as a family what God has
for you and you know that that was that
was difficult for me and then after a
couple of years we joined staff and just
to clarify that was very much the this
definitely isn't necessarily the sort of
the standpoint of a lot of even
Christian churches at this point but
yeah very much the sort of the branch
that we were in you know you've got
egalitarianism and you've got
complementarianism and so we were we
were complimentary and meaning that
they're women and men have specific
roles right and so in the household the
man is supposed to be the spiritual
leader he's the one that kind of
everything falls on to to make sure that
his family is is following God that was
you know our interpretation of some New
Testament passages when we joined staff
of Cru
now my spiritual identity was also my
professional identity and you know I I
was fully committed to God but also now
financially completely dependent on all
these people who believed in what I
believed in and they believed in the
work that we were doing when we raise
financial support so I put even more
pressure on myself because I had these
people investing in our work and I had
and I was doing I was I was a
professional Christian at this point I
should not be good at it should I start
to have a little bit of a Scottish
accent yeah yeah you know but I I had
this nagging sense of being Hollow that
you know I just it was always there I
couldn't quite shake it and around this
time that's when Rhett started talking
about the age of the earth and the
validity of evolution we started talking
about those things would you started
talking about them with me I was you
know I didn't have I don't have doubts
and I don't sit around as I'm falling
asleep or in my spare time just like
having logic battles in my mind it's
just not you know I have that I have the
battles I was having what was I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not doing this good
enough you know I just devoted all of my
energy there but whenever you would
bring something up first of all I knew
like well I'm not gonna panic you know
you made the joke of like Jesse would
start crying because it was perceived as
such a threat and I totally get that it
was I was like I remember having an
internal dialogue of okay just don't
panic be cool about this just be a
sounding board for what Rhett wants to
talk about because you know I'm not
gonna fall for the trap of like well you
know you can't you can't go there
because it might lead to something it's
like I'd so I I mean I started listening
and you know when you read Francis
Collins the language of God in 2006 I
also read that and I was like yeah it's
like I'm convinced in the validity of
evolution and I remember
remember a nun and a unintended
consequence of reading that book was I
just had this sense and we discussed it
that that there was an island with God
on it and it was shrinking as science
discovered more and more and it would
lead ultimately lead to a place where
hope the the waters of science would
cover the top of the island and there
would be no more God you know that's
actually what we were taught in terms of
this odds if you start if you start
looking at evolution it's a slippery
slope as well I would say and I will say
ironically we're not doing Francis
Collins any favors between my story in
your story I you know I'm not I'm not
trying to give us that much credit like
this is little so many people are gonna
listen to this but a lot of people like
Ken Ham you know and getting he like the
head of Answers in Genesis are gonna be
like I told you and he's got an
Australian accent but he's gonna say I
told you you can't believe in evolution
look what happened live you if you if
you if you if you do it if you believe
in it and it's all Francis Collins fault
well I'm very grateful but it I think it
because that wasn't his point in the
book the shrinking Island thing but it's
something that we discussed in that
because we just started asking these
questions of like well if Adam and Eve
never existed doesn't Paul say in the
Bible to the whole point of Jesus's
crucifixion and resurrection was to undo
Adams original sin and then but so it I
don't want to get you know it's like I'm
a professional Christian I don't you
know I'm panicking inside so I'm like
there are answers you can find them you
could anything you want to believe you
can find something right because I
started to find those because as I said
because I was very sick I don't want to
give short shrift to this if that's the
correct word I know there are lots of
Christians who accept evolution as it's
taught as it's understood by scientists
and still believe in Adam and Eve and
they've have there's a way that they
reconcile that I'm very familiar you
don't have to tweet those books at me I
very familiar with that argument I just
think there's some other issues going on
but so yeah it you you can you can
accept both of those things it and I
took comfort in that because I'm I'm
sitting here on staff man I can't you
know it's like what am I gonna what am I
gonna do just like become homeless it
was too much at stake so I kept the most
threatening questions at bay until after
we left staff and so in 2008 up until
2011 I mean that's we we were starting
our career as youtubers and in that
timeframe where we were developing this
new career I was also developing a
growing spiritual disillusionment and
there were two parallel paths for me one
was the intellectual path and then the
other parallel path was the experiential
what was happening to me in my heart and
my my circumstance so I'll talk about
both of those first
I mean intellectually the discussions
that we had they continued I think they
accelerated it was the next thing and
again you can kind of superimpose rets
talk on top of mind whenever he mentions
like dismantling his view it was also my
view of the old testament you know that
the early stuff in the old testament it
can't be literal you know becoming
convinced to that and then continuing to
read the old testament it's like the old
testament god mandated a lot of actions
that troubled me i just you know it was
like you worship a god I mean there's
some I mean I'm not even telling my head
scratchers I'm talking about like oh my
gosh this is frightening hmm our view of
the Bible started to dismantle we were
having lots of conversations about it I
I wasn't I wasn't chomping at the bit to
go home and report all of these
conversations because I didn't I didn't
know I thought it was a thought exercise
you know I didn't
I didn't I didn't know where was gonna
lead and I didn't you know I didn't
wanna that's like man I I want to
process this with Christie but I don't
want to scare so I talked to her about
you know for every one time every eight
times we talked I might I might talk to
her about it once just because it was
yeah a lot of other [ __ ] going on in our
lives I don't want to add that into the
equation
but then the experiential parallel path
was ever ever since graduating from
college and leaving Campus Crusade as a
student like I got a Christian I got
involved in the church different church
than you and it was a small church so
they had an immediate need for someone
to help lead the music and because I had
done that at Campus Crusade they asked
me to do it and I knew I could do it but
I was I was reluctant and increasingly
more over time but you know it was the
right thing to do I was like I can
really I think this is how I can
contribute at my church leading leading
the the praise and worship music I was
like the music leader at my church
up until moving to Los Angeles but there
were a lot of places that I was I guess
I was having an internal existential
crisis you know but I remember it being
very palpable every Sunday morning
because I would get on stage and I would
I would I would pray and I would leave
the music and I would say some things to
help contextualize the songs that we
were singing so that people in the
audience could like really connect with
God yet I found it impossible impossible
for me to be able to connect with God in
that way through music on a Sunday
morning and I remember I would try
harder and hard I would like clamp my
eyes shut and and really concentrate on
the word
that I was singing that were moving
people emotionally and spiritually out
there but for me it it proved it
it was like there was a brick wall there
I just couldn't like I couldn't get
there and that was really frustrating
and I think there's a lot of you know
yeah there were there were practical
aspects of that and it's like you know I
am a performer you're on stage you know
people are watch and even if the goal is
to not be seen and kind of step out of
the way so to speak that's probably
still a factor and and then when I start
thinking about it like I don't know it's
just it I remember after church every
Sunday I would tell Christy I'm just I'm
not who they think I am
they think I'm clamping my eyes shut
because I'm having such a meaningful
experience but I'm clamping my eyes shut
because I can't find anything and I
would talk to a few people about it like
I would mention something and it was you
know it was it's just it's a hairy kind
of thing to get into
so it's and that really started to come
to a head like the the six months
leading up to us moving to LA I felt I
just I started saying things like I just
feel phony
and the conversations we were having
again in parallel were mean it was the
one-two punch of you know I'm not I'm
not experiencing an intimacy with God
and then I don't I'm starting to
question the foundations of everything
that this is built on so they those two
paths fed each other for me well you
know there wasn't just to add a little
color to this speaking of our
conversations we also had another kind
of conversation we had it pretty often
do you remember we would be sitting in
that office in Lillington or even our
office in Fuquay and we would be like
man you know I just feel like we really
haven't been focusing on
the Lord and like a lot of things are
happening and like
I just feel like we need to we need is
recognized yeah how he got where we're
at and and seek the Lord's guidance and
let me and you would just sit there and
pray together yeah we would and we would
have in the first part of the prayer was
as always like Lord man we suck yeah you
know you've given us so much you're
giving us our heart's desire
like we I we we have this career there's
a lot of guilt there was a lot of guilt
there's a lot of shame but even in the
I'm the reason I'm adding that is
because I'm just remembering in the
midst of the again as I hope I made
clear but in the midst of the doubt
there was for both of us I know you're
talking about how you were struggling
with the connection but it was still
paramount it was still central and it
was still kind of what everything was
based on and when we felt like we were
sort of moving forward and without
giving God the credit without consulting
him we felt bad and we would like yea
check in on each other and then pray for
like at least 30 minutes we would just
pray yeah
and when you feel I mean like praying
with somebody was such an intimate thing
it was like it the reason why we didn't
do it was because it was like yeah it
was like this intimate thing that like
it was so super vulnerable we were both
naked but it was like I mean it's like
you know we weren't gonna we weren't
gonna cry together something later but
it was again it was so important that we
were willing to do that I mean I
remember when I was dating Christy like
we wouldn't pray together ironically
like when you get married it's like now
you're the spiritual leader but we
talked we talked about how we were told
not to pray we don't pray together
because that's that's more intimate than
like I don't know a sexual act well
because we heard stories about
boyfriends and girlfriends praying
together and then making out right after
because they were so connected yeah
those prayer kisses that prayer tone
speaking in tongues right there oh I
knew I'd find that joke I'd find it so I
just felt
I felt fed up with this phony feeling
every week and I enough and I felt like
it was on me but I started to question
if it was if it was worth it and I
started to think it looks like we're
gonna move to LA at least for six months
and if it doesn't happen I don't know
I'm just gonna have to step down I just
can't
hey this is not authentic this is not
it's not good for anybody
I didn't I I wasn't saying I was gonna
leave the church but I was gonna but
that would have been like maybe the next
step and I'm in that specific church it
wasn't I didn't know what I believed but
it was just like I mean we were just
having constant conversations and then
we moved to LA and I was so relieved
because it spared me all of these
awkward and painful conversations that I
felt like I was about to have to have
with like my pastor who was like a
really good friend and you know again I
throughout all this I'm not trying to
implicate anybody because I bet anybody
listening I just think about this like
man I wish you would have said something
slightly I know it would have been
probably a gracious response but I know
it would have been but it's like I
didn't want to they want to get into it
and so it was an and tell my family that
I wasn't I wasn't going to church or I
wasn't you know I wasn't serving in the
church the way that it was any more like
things are different you know something
you just don't want to get into it so as
you become a monk you cutting you off
but you but when you express doubt and
in the midst of church a lot of times
people say hey listen if you've got
doubts that's part of the that's part of
the experience and talk to people about
them and and and we did we talked we
talked to a lot of people but it's still
the fact remains that when you raise the
kinds of questions that we were having
you do become a difficult and
complicated person for a church body and
a lot of times those people especially
if they're not satisfied with the
answers they're getting they kind of get
pushed out because I got the flock I got
to worry about there's a little crazy
sheep that's asked
these weird questions yeah he's taken a
lot of time right so I understand
logistically why that happens but I
think you were a little bit scared of
becoming someone's project yeah that's
true yeah which is very much my
experience yeah I had one friend besides
you that I confided in who didn't go to
that church anymore because he was going
somewhere else but I had some I had some
resources and of course Christie but
moving to LA was like a big relief
because I could sidestep the the whole
thing and just like you said we both got
involved in church out there and I was
like well maybe yeah but it's different
out here
and but we went to what's still an
evangelical church because that was our
point of reference and I was like I'm
not gonna make mistake of like
compliment be on stage or anything like
that I'm just gonna receive well I had
like professional musicians yeah yeah I
could have made LA Church is this a
different deal it's like I don't know I
mean you're great but you I don't know
if you would have made the cut just to
be honest I wouldn't make the cut
any guy had an accent he's a British and
just like you much cooler than I was
hopeful that it would be like a time
where I just I could remove the pressure
but I could experience and then I could
experience God but I was very skeptical
by this point because of that parallel
path I I no longer believed in the Bible
as the inerrant Word of God again you
presented a lot of these resources it's
not like I don't want to say I don't
want to go through all that yeah I was I
think it registered I was slowly
crossing the boundary from belief to
disbelief just like you get it's a very
permeable place and it's not just for me
it wasn't just like this one thing
happened but I just started to realize
one day I I had I must have overnight
experience some subtle shift that I was
just ever so slightly on the other side
of a boundary and I was looking at it
from the other side and my growing
two problems with the Bible and
evangelicalism all of a sudden like all
all of that lit those problems that
popped up over my whole life to this
point they had much simpler explanations
when I was looking at it from the
outside and again I was like teetering
but like the teaching of Hell you know
I'm I just wasn't
I was letting go with that plus the I
mean the discrimination of the lbgtq
plus communities within the church I
mean that had troubled me for years and
you I know that and all of a sudden
you're like hold on it's like I can't I
can't accept everybody you know I and
then we were discussing Jesus and as you
said in your story it was like I think
again I don't want to get into the
arguments that like started to sway us
at like to believe that like they're
what he probably didn't raise from the
dead but it's always just this probably
or sisters you just can't know and I
started to feel it was more likely that
he didn't actually raise from the dead
and I just found myself believing that
as the cumulative conclusion of all the
reading that I had also been doing and
the conversations we've been having for
years by this point so my entire belief
system was very tenuous and I you know I
realized I know about myself like you
got the two words belief and system and
I know enough about myself to know that
yeah I thought a lot about the belief
but I cared a lot about the system you
know as a as a perfectionist I took a
lot of comfort in
knowing that there was if I'm just
signed up for all of this like I know
I'm safe eternally I know that as I just
have I trust that like if I don't know
everything that I should believe or
everything I should be doing at least I
will it's all there and I'll get to it
and it was it was it felt very secure
for me someone who I think really value
that really needed to know that I was
doing it right and then I was safe but I
think about this point in my life the
beliefs the questions associated with
the beliefs I was so uncomfortable with
the basis of those and the now the the
practical outcome of those that it
overcome it overcame my interest in
keeping a system I remember we were
taught we would hang out with some
friends and we would discuss some of
this stuff what we were going through
and there was one guy who was you know
great guy he's Christian who said you
know I actually don't I don't want to
hear what you're talking about because I
don't want to lose what I have and I
think you'd probably convince me and
this is working for me and my family so
I love you guys but I just I got a bow
out of this conversation you know and I
got that I understood it I wasn't I
don't think I was hurt by that but I
couldn't and I because I was that way
for a long time as we were talking about
it but I couldn't live like that anymore
I felt like I just I had to face the the
facts or the compelling arguments that I
had never been willing to look at
because I knew of what I needed I was
getting from my faith but again all
those things started to shift you start
to think about the billions of people
who who sought God for a revelation and
they've gotten nothing
or they've received profound revelation
that is in direct contradiction to the
profound revelation that somebody else
has gotten you know it I just found
myself starting to believe that just
like you said that you know humans have
a way of trying to Maga to make sense of
things and so this is just I just found
it most reasonable to believe that the
Bible represented humans trying their
best to explain God and it was one of
many well-developed
explanations across many religions and
they were all accompanied by sincere
experiences to validate them so sure to
say the least Church became a place of
frustration not comfort for me why was
that working so hard to make
Christianity work for me if it wasn't
even true and I think it's because the
the alternative was so scary I mean it
was it was all I knew it was you know
you you gave the analogy of like the
ship and then jumping into this water
and it's like you even look over the
side of the ship and you're like man
it's like everything I've taught is that
it's it's real ugly down there but at a
certain point you kind of find that
you're in midair falling into it anyway
I mean it's that you can lead a horse to
water but you can't make him drink you
can lead you can't make someone fall in
love with you you can't if you find
yourself falling out of love everybody
raised yeah if I must to replace the the
Bible with Bonnie Raitt well I yeah I
can I completely relate with an agreed
everything that you're saying and I
think that I thought a little bit more
about that the boat analogy and the the
fact is is that and I think this is one
of the reasons that you know our friend
was like hey don't rock my boat
mm-hmm-hmm is because it is a boat if
the boats not fake right you know I'm
saying it's like
it is a system it is beneficial it has
helped millions of people it's helping
millions of people right now it has
stood the test of time so of other
religions but yeah it's if it because
people are like Iran did it was it no
way if it wasn't real what what about
your life change in your growth well no
there was real life change there was
real growth there was real community
there was the all these experiences were
real in a sense we're just saying that
we think that they were most likely
happening in our minds and in everyone
else's minds which are incredibly
powerful things it doesn't mean that the
change isn't real some some people that
I know we're not telling my story or be
like but listen I know it's real because
of what Jesus did in my life let me tell
you my testimony
yeah I'm not denying that your life
hasn't changed and that's what I'm
saying there's sincere experiences to
validate all kinds of every every belief
system yeah and so I just you know I it
but I just can't I that's not compelling
me this horse to drink that water
what does at this point another way it
doesn't make it true doesn't make it
true you might make it true or feel true
to you but it doesn't necessarily make
it universally true so it because you
had an experience so at this point I
mean again we're we must have been
discussing this because you use the term
like you conducted an experiment and I
definitely remember using that term at
the time I think it it was a way to say
hey I'm just gonna ease I'm gonna ease
into believing differently and see what
happens it's not you know it can just be
private I wrote in my journal November
5th 2013 again this was addressed to God
but it's the last journal entry that
I've written like I I don't well really
yeah well that's not actually that's not
true
for a long time it was this is what I
meant to say it was the last journal
entry that I wrote address to God Oh
and this is not the beginning this is a
part in the middle and I think I wrote
this as kind of a record for myself too
you can see in the way I wrote it it was
just like I want to know that this was
the point this is the date the point in
my life when I got when I when I felt
this way and I'm glad I did because I
wouldn't have known it was November 5th
2013 here's what I wrote since moving
out here and that's to LA and combined
with Rett sharing his evolving
perspective I have slowly given up
trying to be the Christian that I feel
like I've been trying to be all these
years I've concluded that I'm not going
to do the things I've always done the
right things the spiritual disciplines
and expect different results intimacy
with God or even more directly I'm gonna
give up feeling guilty for not being
better and doing better at Christianity
and this experiment has felt good
freeing for the most part everything
except feeling like I'm letting Christie
and the kids down at this point I'm not
sure if God exists and you see my
mindset at that time it was its it
seemed like I was just saying I'm gonna
stop I'm gonna stop feeling so guilty
for the things I'm not doing to try to
be a good Christian but and so it sounds
like I'm like but I'm I'm just gonna be
a Christian I'm gonna let go and let God
and I do think that's what a lot of
people who may be hearing in mice they
that's not maybe how they're responding
to my story is that like you know we all
go through those this times in the
struggles you're having it's kind that's
common every person who's like very
serious about pursuing Jesus but I I
think what was really happening was yes
that was my true experience even though
I sincerely sought God my entire life
but it primed me to be open to dealing
with what I felt were the the
intellectual things that I didn't listen
in this journal entry but I think that's
what held the weight to make the
decision that's what eroded the
foundation and it was very important
to me and like I said I it felt freeing
like I didn't I didn't I was surprised
that I didn't experience a sense of
extreme loss I was afraid of what it
would mean for just like you said will
mean for my marriage because I had
believed that a Christian and a
non-christian can't stay married like do
it but I actually I I just couldn't live
I couldn't pretend anymore
and I and so one of the things that I
called into question was if that was
true
like I never would have done it if I
thought it was still true that I was
gonna lead a divorce I would have just
you put my head down and intrude on but
I actually believed that like our
marriage could still be vibrant I had no
clue how that would work though I
believed that I could still be a great
father to my kids and that they would be
okay I felt like my kids will be better
people I could influence them in the
best way possible by being as honest
with them as possible for appropriate to
their ages versus trying to give them a
what I believed was a false sense of
security and teaching something much
less because I wasn't going to give him
the fear version that I gotten so I felt
okay about it but I still went to church
with Christie and the kids because I
didn't want to be that guy like I'd I
had judged hard the guy who would not go
to church with his family it's like what
a jackass that's what I felt like I was
like so I ain't gonna be that guy right
but it was so it was so difficult
because again it was a it was a place of
frustration not a place of comfort from
me and anything that was said I would
always try to derive what it was based
on and like I was like man this is all
Sh
this is all shifting sand that you're
that you're building all this on that's
how I would feel I would get frustrated
I remember on Easter Sunday we were all
sitting in the minivan and
I was it's like I don't think I can go
in there and Chrissy was crying and we
ended up taking the kids into the youth
group and coming back to the minivan I
just sitting there in the parking lot
and just bawling our eyes out Chrissy it
was she'd been I think it was she was
still one year after her brain injury
which again it was like an extreme low
point for her I was saying I don't think
I can go in there and she was saying I
don't think I cannot go in there anyway
you know I we it wasn't we were
grappling with our how our beliefs were
changing and it was something that we
were talking about much more than when I
referenced it earlier like one out of
every eight times we would talk now
there was something that we were talking
about a lot now I was not keeping it
from Christie or the kids but she she
was in a place like the most difficult
thing was happening in in her brain and
in her body and suffering from post
concussion syndrome which she still
suffers from many years later it was an
extreme low point for her and it was
like she she she was wrestling with it
but she couldn't she couldn't do that it
was much more at stake for her than
there was for me at that point
so I III would go to church with them
and then I would I would just explain
the things that I have trouble would
become a you know a part of our
conversations that we'd have as a family
because I was just like you know I just
want to I want everybody to be able to
start to think for themselves and not
have something shoved down their throat
I don't think anybody was doing that so
I thought okay with it in the church and
in our conversations but over time I you
know I eventually stopped going to
church and then my family and
just going it wasn't too long after that
but you know that the the thing that
happened was I the specific issue of the
LGBTQ issues and how the the church was
a welcoming place and a loving place but
then when you really got down to it they
weren't accepted as couples there was a
you know you can be married there and
that really ate away at me and you know
it's I mean and this was a long time
coming and there's a minute we had been
having many conversations for many years
about this issue and wrestling with it
ourselves but as we made meaningful
connections with people here like I'll
just give Stevie and Cassie as an
example like not just working together
but being friends and loving them and
understanding how they love each other
and how and yeah many other couples and
I just I just could not I couldn't sit
in the seat knowing that they couldn't
you know that they couldn't get married
there I just felt like it was a betrayal
of my friends and then of what I believe
what I believed you know so that was in
and so then I didn't go back and what
and I'll add to this especially in a
place like Los Angeles I mean it might
if you're you know there's plenty of
there's plenty of evangelical churches
where it's you would know just
unequivocally like okay this is not
necessarily a gay friendly place even
though they may be loving and say
something like love the you know love
the sinner hate the sin the old cliche
but especially in LA and in LA they
wouldn't say they would never say that
but that's the
leave well what I'm gonna is in LA there
the churches and the people leading the
churches are smart enough to know that
they cannot have an outwardly anti LGBTQ
stance because they wouldn't have
anybody show up and there's plenty of
LGBTQ people who go to these places on a
regular basis and they don't even know
that if you dig deep enough if you put
the pastor in a corner if you backed him
or her into a corner and said do you
believe that marriage is only between a
man and a woman they would say yes
because they they have a particular
interpretation of the Bible that leads
them into that conclusion now there's
plenty of churches that would say no
we're Pro LGBTQ so but I'm just saying
that that is a thing that you kind of
run into in LA is like all the outward
signs are that this is a super loving
and accepting place and it is a loving
place we're not talking about a bunch of
bigoted people but when it gets down to
it the theology sort of leads them to a
place that they're not completely
accepting and affirming and that's kind
of the situation that you found yourself
in yeah and and I think that well I know
that also resonated with my family and
was a major contributor to to saying you
know what let's just let's just ease out
listen let's ease out of this or let's
well let's step out and that's what we
did and we lived happily ever after
no I mean I guess some people are
thinking could we have found a more
liberal LGBTQ affirming Church yes you
know I think you looked around and it
was just there is a church that if when
I go to church I go to I go to this
church that is yeah as if it is an
affirming Church you don't really go but
don't really go I go I'll go I'll go
sometimes I think like me I didn't
Christmas like I'm just not ready to go
to church in general and I may never be
I'm just not ready to enter back into a
specific system of belief even if it's
different and it aligns with like the
practical application
of that belief system are exactly in
line with how I want to live my life I
just like I'm I'm maybe I'm still just
too close or have been in it so long
that I just I feel like I need more
distance from it I just can't I didn't
and it there's a lot of like at least
all the places that are that meet that
check those boxes they're like very
what's the word ecumenical right and
it's like okay that's like a high church
thing and it's like I don't think I
would thrive well under that system
because yeah I rod much as I love
systems I do think that as I'm beginning
to learn about myself and as I read
those journal entries to you and like my
my internal dialogue I think you're
seeing as I am appreciating that like I
put a lot of pressure on myself and I I
didn't I don't interact in a healthy way
at this point in my life with a robust
belief system yeah so I mean you ended
up saying you applied the label of like
hopeful agnostic to to where you were
right now and I mean if I were to put if
I were to label myself I think I would
say I'm an agnostic who wants to be
hopeful I think I have made a decision
to be open I do want that I don't want
to be I just you know I don't want to be
an atheist
so I'm hopeful that I can be hopeful but
it I I know that it can be an atheist
because I'm not I'm not convinced that
God doesn't exist and I don't want to
you know I if God does exist I want to
be open to that connection you know I
you know I'm
that's just not it's not how I think
like to come down hard on something and
like but I think that left to my own
devices from a practical standpoint I
would end up and as like a practical
atheist where it's like you know what I
do feel like it's easiest for me to
believe that when you die it's just like
Dana Carvey my my Wayne's World
doppelganger I'm replacing the Bible
with Garth and Bonnie Raitt it seems but
I remember years ago when I was
listening to WTF podcast Dana Carvey was
talking about how he believed it like
when you die if it's just like the
experience you had before you were born
you remember that so I'm like yeah
that's oh that that's actually
comforting and I actually I find it easy
to believe that for some reason it's not
you know I'm not compelled to believe it
but it's just an easy place for my mind
to rest well and you don't have to
believe it I think the reason I'm not an
atheist is because it just feels too
definitive is it right agnostic is the
label that literally means you don't
know and I hope I'm always but when it
comes to these issues I hope I I'm
always I don't want I just don't but I
don't want to become dogmatic about
anything yeah but I don't want to become
complacent either because I do think
that is its easiest for me to believe
that everybody believes whatever they
want to believe like your innermost
desires maybe that's I mean it could be
something primal like survival and
security and it could I mean there's so
many different things but like we have a
way of finding what works for us
and I think that's instinctive so just
to put it bluntly you believe what you
want to believe you know it's like I
find it easy to believe that I find it
easy to believe that because so many
people have had so many earth-shattering
experiences that are in complete
contradiction that it's like probably
means that God's not personal you know
it's like he makes maybe God is personal
and that God is just great at relating
very specifically to a lot of different
people in a very
personal way that makes sense to them
and you don't know but you know why I'm
open to that that would be a very loving
isn't God capable of doing that again
when I'm not I'm not gonna see her and
try to invent a new belief system I like
this is what I believe specifically i I
just want to do the work to stay open
but not to get like you said dogmatic
and I know that that takes work it's
good it takes an investment of time and
priority for me to not just sit back and
just kind of be just go with the flow of
like I'm not looking again it's not
looking for the next thing to latch onto
and believe and start to follow but it's
being open to what how God may exist and
may want to connect with me
I think the main thing is I don't want
to judge I don't want to condemn I want
to be as loving as I can maybe that
sounds trite it does but so what I want
to be as loving as I can and you know I
do feel like over the past few years my
capacity to love has grown my capacity
to love myself and others has expanded a
lot more in in the last few years and I
yeah I take that as a good sign I don't
I just don't think that God if God
exists or however God exists I just
can't believe that and I that me being
open and sincere and as loving as
possible
and as honest as possible is
disqualifying me from receiving God's
love
I just I can't accept that
oh and so I have hope that that's true
because I can't I cannot just decide to
be or believe something that I don't and
I'm I'm just that's not gonna stop a lot
of people on the internet from trying to
give at you though yeah and I feel like
because a lot I feel like a lot of what
I said could be boiled down as neuroses
you know it's like but it but the
intellectual Pat I mean it's the two
thing I think the one made me receptive
to the to the other and I just think
it's got to be so Indies and that's
truth I just don't know how people will
respond to what I just said though when
I'm like I want to be open I don't know
I'm an agnostic I just wanted to focus
on love and then I'm like but the reason
I got here is because of what I was
convinced that was no longer true well I
can tell you how I would have reacted to
it when I was a Christian and I would
have been sad for you mm-hmm and I think
there's gonna be a lot of people who are
sad for us there's a lot of people who
are gonna feel sorry for us and they're
gonna be like I just I can't you know I
asked a close friend was like so do you
think I'm going to hell and he was like
I don't know I don't I think um I think
what you had was real and it still is
and you're at this and Europe you're
you're in a process I don't he didn't
say I think you'll come back I think
maybe it's forward and on the other side
and but it's like I appreciated that in
one sense I guess in the and the other
sense it's like I don't feel like I'm
gonna go back in a cent to any of the
like like the specific
Alysse about the Bible yeah you know so
I mean that's that's where I'm at
and that's the conclusion of my story to
this point but it's obviously not the
conclusion of my journey and I'm
immediately thinking about how people
are responding to it and I'm just trying
not to do that yeah well but I want to
be a conversation to happen yeah well
maybe we can help
listen I'm not trying to be I'm not
trying to dictate how the conversation
should go from here but let me just say
just a couple of thoughts that I have
about the conversation that will happen
as a result of these stories kind of
going out to the public most people and
I totally get why this is a case are
going to interact with our stories in
whatever way makes sense according to
their predetermined worldview right so
if you're a Christian and you're not a
Christian that has had a lot of doubts
or you're just like a hundred percent
sure that you're right
you're most likely you're gonna filter
us through your theology just like I was
talking about at the beginning of my
story so you may conclude that well you
guys were definitely never actual
Christians it was an intellectual thing
that that's specifically addressed in
the Bible and you know God's gonna say
he never knew you and if that makes you
you know I understand why you have to
believe that I don't accept that but I
can't make you change your mind and then
there's a lot of other situations that
people may find it but you're gonna make
it consistent with your predetermined
beliefs the only thing I asked about and
I hope that this was clear and link made
it I try to make it clear and link try
to make it clear that we are just kind
of telling our story trying to be as
honest as possible about what transpired
in our lives that kind of led us to this
point and I would love if the
conversation would be tell us your story
right or minoo you don't have to like I
said I know people are gonna send a lot
of arguments probably especially to me
because I'm the one that talked about
all the you know the specific arguments
about evolution
Old Testament archaeology and that kind
of thing so people are gonna try to send
resources and books have you heard of
this if you read this article and I'm
not saying don't do that some people
won't be able to help yourself cuz I
wouldn't been able to help myself if I
was in your shoes you know but I would
just hope that you would just actually
try to consider our stories from the
point of hey we're just humans trying to
be honest where your online friends
trying to be honest and just consider
just consider the story on its face
don't just immediately try to fix us try
to fix us or try to make it fit into
your system because I think that that's
I think that the world has got so much
polarization right now people are like
I'm right you're wrong
that's it and more than ever and it's
interesting we're so we're much but so
we're so much better connected to one
another than we've ever been but we're
also so divided and it's this just
horrible irony that's kind of the nature
of the information agent I I just don't
want that kind of conversation to happen
in our community where people are
throwing rocks at each other and you
know insulting one another and calling
you know listen there's gonna be people
from both ends of the spectrum who are
gonna get engaged in this conversation
please see people's humanity see our
humanity and don't just resort to just
putting your feet and into your trench
and just holding your position consider
somebody to consider somebody's
viewpoint you know I also wonder if
people's takeaway is you know like dang
Lincoln foot one Freret you might you
might be in a better place you know it's
like he really brought you down you know
it's absolutely true that you know and
that I wouldn't I wouldn't have been
grappling with these issues I don't
I probably wouldn't have been grappling
with issues I probably wouldn't have
done it you know because
as as a hard time as I was having I
still didn't want you know it was still
ultimately this so very safe for me and
I don't really need that
but I'm very grateful that that that
your personality is different than mine
in that way that it was my active choice
at every turn to actively engage in the
discussion and I didn't you know we
shared some so much of our lives in our
spiritual journey was so similar that we
we had the exact same language and so
many the same experiences we went on all
the same Church trips and we were party
to all the same prayer groups and you
know so whenever I really benefited and
kind of a hack to the system in a lot of
ways I feel like yes I trusted you but
it was almost like trusting your
response to it was very trustworthy as
my own response because eirick journeys
were so in lockstep and then I but I
there was pivotal points all along the
way when I would have to pick up those
books and read them it wasn't just the
Francis Collins one because it's
starting to get real and it was like I
got to read this stuff for myself
I'll that'll transition to my well I'll
let you respond to that because I think
that people might say it's your fault it
is no I mean no I'm very conscious of
that I I think that I mean interestingly
the the other way around I mean like in
any sort in any testimony that you give
that you hear somebody give in the
church it usually comes down to a person
who share the gospel with them right
like it's people share the message and
for better or worse it also works the
other way it's like I'm a key figure in
your anti testimony you know it's just
it's just it's a fact it's and
and and I think that yeah people will be
upset about that people will be mad at
me I don't doubt that but I'm letting
you off the hook because again I'm I'm
grateful for it and I'm fully
responsible for it
did it make the conversations that I had
with Christie even more difficult yes
because it was I was presenting these
beliefs that were a threat to her they
were genuine questions to me but they
were also tied to you like whispering it
in my ear you know
and so we had to you know we had to work
through that as well it's like well is
is this is this something that you're
grappling with or something that Rhett
is grappling with you know ultimately
it's something that I'm grateful that
legitimate questions are things that I
actually wrestled with I think I need
and that goes back to my intention of
working to be hopeful because I feel
like it does - it does take work for me
to engage in those questions the
difficult questions in order to become
more of who I actually want to be yeah
that's not easy although all the
decisions were yours I all I did was
just present information as I was
processing it and at no point was I
trying to convince you of anything and
at no point was I trying to like I was
the only person I talked to who would
listen I was you just talk really talk
yeah I was confiding but and I think
that I did not want to in my session
here
I didn't want to retread the reasons
that you gave the arguments that were
compelling for you that was because you
you gave some of those and you gave
resources but I also didn't want to do
it because I didn't want to I didn't
want to share a story that was you know
when whenever my belief started to pivot
I described those in like a timeline
fashion but I intentionally didn't
describe what is it but it made you
believe that Jesus didn't raise from the
dead what is it that made you believe
that
you couldn't that you did she saw Paul
differently or you know all of the
arguments I didn't make them because I
feel like as a listener it's up to them
it's up to you to to look into that if
you want to but I've also I also feel
like I was giving you an out if like hey
this is working for me like our friends
that had that was like if if you if this
is working for you then you know I don't
want to be the one just screwing it
screw it up for you like red did for me
[Laughter]
but I do invite you and I'll make a rag
but you know I found this book called
why I believed reflections of a former
missionary written by Kenneth W Daniels
feel like I'm on Reading Rainbow now I
mean this it's a freaking self-published
book ken published a book it's very
highly rated but it's very specific it
was it was perfect for me because it was
Ken was like a Bible translator who like
raised finances just like we did and but
he's such a thorough thinker he's like
he's kind of like the two of us combined
because you know this is the guy that I
want to be he talked in terms of how
well he he researched on he talked in
equal parts about his own experience of
deconstruction and like he's quoting his
own journal entries in here so you
really understand what's going on his in
his heart as well as his mind and so if
you relate to the specifics of coming
out of evangelicalism especially if you
like if you were in the ministry or if
you are in the ministry and you you want
to have them you want to read something
that has a more personal touch than that
that this is this is a profound book for
me so ken thank you for publishing this
book but again
if you don't want to get into it don't
don't don't read it don't read it just
so you can dismiss it don't read
anything just as message just don't even
read it if that's what you're gonna do
but again you gave resources last time
and that's another one to add to the
list all time and you know I appreciate
your story because I mean my guess is
that more people relate to your story
than mine that I just that's my in my
experience when I talk about the things
that happen with me again like I said a
lot of people just are like you're crazy
like what why do you think about these
things here or it or at least well he
lost me
yeah and looks like I meant a lot to him
but like I don't think it matters that
much and I think yours was very personal
and it was about what you were kind of
experiencing on a practical level which
I think more people were relate to I
would just say again as we you know
begin to have a conversation listen what
the next podcast is not but we don't
know it's gonna be about but it we're
gonna take a break from this subject
matter but like I said I think that this
stuff the spiritual stuff is going is
now a part of your biscuits you know
it's it will be something that we talk
about whether we talk about you know our
past and we want to answer more
questions I know that there's lots of
questions that people have related to
these stories I can only imagine
so ask those questions we'll try to be
as clarifying as we can and if you make
us think about something in a different
way well we'll let you know I mean we
want this to be a process we want this
to be a conversation but we're gonna let
those questions be generated and and
then we'll continue that conversation at
another time yeah so hashtag your
biscuits and also again I'll encourage
you to share these episodes with people
that you know it would it would resonate
with or spark more conversations between
you and your friends so share it will
speak at you next week probably about
something else out something else and
we'll we'll see if we most likely will
come back to it thank you
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]